- Melted cheese on top of
bread, is that a sandwich?
- [Ned] That is a sandwich.
- So a pizza's a sandwich, Ned?
- Unfortunately, yes.
- No, no!
- You might love hotdogs.
You might love sandwiches.
But is that hotdog also a sandwich?
Today we're gonna get to the bottom
of this once and for all. Let's go.
- I think hotdogs are sandwiches.
- And I think hotdogs are not sandwiches.
- I believe that hotdogs are sandwiches.
- I'm holding one sandwich,
but that is also a sandwich and a hotdog.
- A hotdog is a hotdog, my friends.
- The logic is that the
definition of a sandwich is
some sort of filling in between bread.
- Technically, it's not in between.
It's laying on the bread.
- I know colloquially we all
know hotdogs aren't sandwiches,
but we're a society built on rules.
As it stands, you have to look at
how the dictionary's written.
- It's like rectangles and squares.
A square is a rectangle, but
a rectangle's not a square.
Just because you don't
call a hotdog a sandwich
doesn't mean it's not a sandwich.
It's still technically a sandwich.
You just call it a hotdog.
- I gotta interject here 'cause
this is driving me crazy.
I think that your logic is flawed.
I think people and the
way language is used--
- Zack, why bother even
having a dictionary?
- Ned, can I get my argument out?
- Nobody is trying to argue
that a hotdog is not a hotdog.
That would be ridiculous.
I'm just arguing that
it is also a sandwich.
- You have commitment problems, my friend.
- If you say that a hotdog is a sandwich,
all of a sudden, anything
can be a sandwich.
We believe that an open-faced sandwich
is a sandwich, correct?
- Avocado toast, yes.
- Okay, so what about melted
cheese on top of bread?
Is that a sandwich?
- That is a sandwich.
- So a pizza's a sandwich, Ned?
- Unfortunately, yes.
- No, no!
- If you want a hotdog,
how will you tell that to your friends?
- I would say I want a hotdog.
- So a hotdog is a hotdog,
not a motherfuckin' sandwich.
You wouldn't say "Go
get a sandwich," right?
'Cause then what would happen?
- Because a hotdog is not the
most readily available image
of a sandwich does not
make it not a sandwich.
- Eugene, get in here.
Is pizza a sandwich?
- No, it is not.
- Is a hotdog a sandwich?
- Fuck, no!
- Damn right, Ned!
- You don't see sandwiches
sold in hotdog places.
You don't see hotdogs
sold in sandwich places.
- You know, it's all
about perception, okay?
I honestly don't even really
like hotdogs that much,
but I just don't think they're sandwiches.
- If you think it's about
perception verses facts,
then saying a hotdog is not a sandwich
is just an alternative fact.
(sobbing)
- I believe that you
have to stand for things,
and once you start making
words encompass everything,
society falls to shit.
- I get the other side. I get it.
But something about
calling a hotdog a sandwich
just makes my blood curl.
I don't know what it is.
I can't describe it scientifically,
like in a dictionary like Jordan can,
but sometimes,
you just have a really
strong feeling about things,
and you just know you're
right, and I'm right.
Whatever, bye.
- If Merriam-Webster
changes the dictionary,
I'll change my side.
- People who think that
hotdogs are sandwiches,
this is the person whose team you're on.
The person who's saying
that pizza's a sandwich.
If you believe that pizza's
a sandwich, I can't help you.
- It is interesting that you said
you know, "something in between breads".
Kind of made me think a little bit.
Like what is a sandwich?
What makes things things?
What is life, you know?
So, thank you, Jordan.
- Please hug.
(laughs)